i think it's uh
i'd like to thank the simons institute
for holding this uh symposium
and the speakers have been really great
and thank christos for
inviting me to come speak you know it's
hard to think of any
technology an area of endeavor that's
had a bigger impact on
humanity in the last 50 years than
computing and
i think that's going to continue for
another 50 years and to even play a
small part i think we should all be very
grateful so i feel that way
so um i'm going to talk today about
machine intelligence is about the
neocortex
and let's just get right into it i've
lived my life basically trying to
pursue two principles the number one
here is the primary one for me
so i was just interested in how the
brain works i wanted to how my brain
worked and i specifically
i was interested in understanding the
principles by which the neocortex works
and so that's been a very long pursuit
for me for over 30 years
but if you um you realize quickly if you
understand how the new york cortex works
you understand the principle is that
there's no reason you can't implement
those principles
in um in other substrates and build
intelligent machines and that's my
belief that the way to build machine
intelligence
learning machines is to study the brain
first that is not a widely held belief
so it's growing but that's where i've
come from
my talk is the agenda for my talk i'm
going to start
off a very brief history of machine
intelligence i'm going to try to define
machine intelligence at least how i view
it
i'm going to talk about uh the progress
we've made and understanding how the
neocortex works
and i'm going to talk about the state of
the art that's um grockets the name of a
product we built it's
uh i'm gonna tell you but at least it's
showing you how the stuff is working i'm
a believer that if you've uh
if you're gonna make an impact you have
to figure out how to get your theories
and your
in your science into the practical world
so i'm trying to do that
and then at the very end of the talk
we've been asked to speculate a bit
about the future
and be about i'm going to talk a little
bit the future of machine intelligence
so let's just jump right into it um i
must be the fourth or fifth presenter to
start off with a picture of alan turing
i
i guess there's something about him that
permeates this room this week
um so uh we all i think everyone's very
very enamored with alan for all the
things he did
uh he was very interested in machine
intelligence and
starting in the mid 1930s 1935 was the
first paper in a series of papers from
there
there on he uh was uh he talked about
computers as being universal machines
and he believed of course that you could
since
uh it was a universal machine he could
emulate what a brain does and he was a
total believer that
we could build intelligent machines he
was actually he wrote about this he
didn't really want to get in arguments
with people about that he was faithful
fearful of people saying oh he's you
know
people are conscious or this or that and
so he didn't talk about too much but in
1950 he came out with the paper where he
introduced the turing machine that's
i'm paraphrasing him here those aren't
his direct quotes but
um he came out with this paper was the
you know the uh
the computing machinery intelligence and
what he's basically said with the turing
test
was he said look i want to get an
argument with you if we can pass the
turing test you just have to agree that
the machine is intelligent so let's just
leave it at that
well there's my mind this is a very
unfortunate thing he did
because what he did with the turing test
he set up the idea that machine
intelligence is about
replicating human capabilities uh not a
more general thing about what it means
to learn and build a model world and so
on but and specifically
being able to replicate human
conversation
which in my mind is a very limiting and
very difficult challenge at the same
time it's limiting because
the manifestations of machine
intelligence can be very very different
than what humans are like
and very difficult at the same time
because to pass as a human you need to
be a lot more than just intelligent
you have to be have human emotions and
human experiences and things like that
so i think this in some way set us down
a poor path
many many years ago i still like the guy
um but that was the beginning
one argues of ai artificial intelligence
and
and uh i call ai sort of the no
neuroscience approach this is what you
know basically we don't need to
understand how brains work
uh we got powerful computers we can
figure this stuff
out uh there's been many many
initiatives over the years
and um i'm wouldn't matter what i say
i'm i'll be over generalizing and
insulting somebody
but the point of this has been many
different types of things it continues
on today
there's lots of uh exciting stuff that's
happened in this area and is happening
many big initiatives we had the mit ai
lab it was big for many many years
uh some of you might remember in the
1980s japan had the fifth generation
computing project which was going to
build
machines are smarter than humans and
that scared a lot of people in the u.s
and so we came up with our counterpart
to that the
the um the strategic computing
initiative
one thing we can say about about ai is
is that the good thing about it is it
came up with lots of good solutions and
it's been very very useful hell i want
to have a google driving car
um but uh but there's some negatives to
it first of all the the solutions tend
to be very task specific
they don't generalize like a
self-driving car does not
know how to do math or physics but i
could do both
to some degree and they're also limited
or no learning and
in my mind intelligence is all about
learning and so
a lot of these systems have very limited
learning capabilities or some have done
whatsoever we programmed in the
knowledge we programmed in the
experience and so on
there's a whole nother drift in in the
machine intelligence world which is a
the neural network
and world and this this starts back with
mcculloch and pitts and someone
mentioned them yesterday as well
uh warren mcculloch and walter pitts
they uh published this paper in 1943
which was caught a lot of people's
attention and in that they described
that neurons could be thought of as like
logic gates
and therefore if you hook them together
you can build logic circuits and things
like computers and so neural networks
are good for computation
now they got a lot of things wrong but
the idea was pretty interesting
the neurons that they proposed and it's
not clear i've never been able to find
out if they really believe this or just
we're using this as an example
but they propose neurons are really like
logic gates you know they have two or
three inputs and they do ands and ors
and things like that
they have negative inputs and positive
inputs real learns are nothing like this
whatsoever
they are very complex with thousands of
inputs they have nonlinearities in their
dendrites they have all kinds of
complications that goes on inside of
them
so this wasn't really at all like a
neural network but it said these guys
get credit because they were the first
people to say
you know what maybe we should be
thinking about taking neuron like
elements and putting them in a network
and seeing what that can do because
that's how brains are built
so that was pretty cool that led to the
whole field of artificial neural
networks
which is a very very broad area and you
cannot paint it with a single brush
i call this the the almost no
neuroscience because even though it has
the word
neural network in its title the vast
majority of the work that's been done
here
ignores most of what we know about
neuroscience there are very simplistic
neurons and connected in ways that are
not we don't see typically in the brain
we know a lot about the brain
uh many many many techniques over the
years the current hot one right now is
deep learning which is really just a
multiple layer
uh feed forward neural network with some
cool learning algorithms associated you
might have been hearing about that
recently
so the good thing about this is that
these are learning systems so that's
great we've got learning systems
they are very good at certain things
mostly classification
and the downside is that they're very
limited capability there's no neural
network that's
getting up in other biological ones that
can do anything of any
sophistication you might consider
intelligent and they're not brain-like
at all as i already mentioned
lately there's been a third
major thrust here which i call maximal
neuroscience this starts off with the
human brain project in europe
you might be familiar with that this is
a multi-billion dollar just got funded
project to basically simulate an entire
brain from ion channels up to
who knows what that rosette chart in the
middle is all the principal researchers
working on this project
and um we of course in good fashion
united states have come back recently a
month or so ago with the brain
initiative
which was originally going to be uh
mapping the entire brain and then they
kind of backed off in that so now we
actually don't know what it is yet
um but i think because people thought it
was a little bit too ambitious or maybe
it wasn't the right thing so who knows
what's going to happen with that
but what we can say here is that i know
this for a fact at least for the for the
human brain project
is that it's really not based on any
sort of theoretical basis it's
essentially
let's simulate it and see what happens
um and so the work is not theoretically
grounded there's no principles really
that they're
adhering to and as far as i can tell
there's no interest in
machine intelligence i'm not saying
these are not good projects i'm just
saying that that's
that's not things that they do uh
there's lots of other good things that
can come out of them
so of course you know some things are
too much some things are too little
there's got to be a happy medium in
between
uh what's the goldilocks approach to
just the right approach
and at least i'm this is my
justification for where i go about it
i think we need to basically start
looking at the neuroscience in detail
but you have to understand the
principles by which it works the process
that we typically go through
my team is we start with anatomy and
physiology histology
is a big part of it and um we from that
we derive theoretical principles we test
that in software empirically against
real natural and artificial data sets we
come back and test
go back again but we view the
neuroscience as a set of constraints
to me if we know something about how the
brain is structured if we know something
about how neurons work
you can't ignore that you can you can
once you think you have a theory why
it's doing that you can back off and say
i don't need to do that
but you can't just willy-nilly say oh
there's too much data there or i
we don't know enough there's a
tremendous amount we know and we have a
huge number of constraints that the
brain tells us about how it implements
uh intelligence finally of course this
stuff has to be implemented in silicon
and that will happen we actually have
started a
i'll tell you in a moment we've started
up a program with the ibm in this regard
because we have we've made some
interesting progress in this whole field
okay so uh that's the first i'm going to
take i'm now going to start um
talk about a little bit what the
neocortex does of course you should all
know the neocortex is about 80
of the volume of your brain all high
level thought and language and
behavior and inference and so on is
occurring up there i knew cortes is
speaking and yours is listening
now the new cortex the first thing you
need to know about it it's a memory
system it's not a computer
it's a memory system it's it stores
patterns and it recalls patterns
um and there's no that's that's
basically what it does it's very unusual
memory system but it's a memory system
it the inputs to it are from your senses
and of course the sensors are not as
simple as you think they are the
the optic the retina is really a million
sensors it's an array of a million
sensors
your body has another array of a million
sensors your audit your cochlear is
another ray of 30
000 sensors and these patterns on these
these bits are coming in are changing
very rapidly in the order of tens of
milliseconds
that's rapid for biology and for brains
and it's and it's you've got this flood
of data coming in and the brain is
taking this in
and it has to build the model of the
world uh so that's what it's doing it's
it's building a model of the world and
from that model
it can make predictions it can detect
anomalies and it generates behaviors
now of course the brain actually
interacts with the world we behave and
and we interact in fact if you think
about the changes that are occurring on
your senses
most of them are occurring due to your
own behavior
so i'm hearing myself speak that's
mostly what i'm hearing and that's my
own creation and if i move my hand and
these things move in my my body
i'm creating this change in the world
not all the things you guys are moving
around doing things too
but a large part of what we experience
when i turn my head and so on
is basically patterns that i've
generated
and so when we want to understand how we
build the model of the world it's not
just how the world behaves it's how the
world behaves as i act on the world
which is a large part of it so it's a
what the neural cortex
does is it learns a sensory motor model
of the world it says
given the current patterns that are
coming in and the history of my
my those patterns in the history of my
behavior and my next behavior what
should occur
and can i imagine what the next events
are going to be and that's how we plan
and think
forward in time so from my point of view
intelligence
if i were to find it and i do i i define
intelligence
as the ability to learn a sensory motor
model of the world
it's that ability to learn it it doesn't
say how smart you are
um it could be fairly simple it could be
very complex but it's that ability to
the world i learn a sensory model model
of the world
um let me go back to that notice here um
i'm not saying anything else i'm not
saying you have to have language i'm not
saying you even have to have a body
uh i'm not saying any of those things
you have to be able to act on the world
and you have to be able to sense the
world and you have to be able to build a
model
world and that's what intelligence all
about
okay uh let's just jump into it i'm
gonna i'm gonna give you my list of
my top six principles by which the
neocortex works
and then we're gonna delve into a few of
them in detail so
the number one principle uh by and not
number one in terms of priority just the
number one i'm going to talk about
is it's an online learning system from
streaming data i've already said that
it's worth emphasizing again the brain
does not store
input patterns it doesn't go back and
look at statistics of them later and say
oh let's batch this up and take a look
at what happened
it has to act and learn in real time
it's an online learning system
uh there's no buffer there for for going
back and checking things later
uh so we that's uh and it's and it's
working from a streaming data source
the second thing is is that we know that
neoquartex is is a hierarchy
of memory regions so let me know it
looks like a big sheet of cells
those cells are connected together in a
hierarchy of regions
and the information comes in and flows
up that hierarchy and down that
hierarchy
this is a this is a chart that every
neuroscientist loves
uh it's a felon vanessa chart showing
the the regions in the
[ __ ] monkey's brain i'm not everyone in
this room may have seen this because
this is a computer science room
but every neuroscientist knows this
chart these little colored boxes are
regions of the neocortex
you've got hundreds of them in your
brain and this is showing
the monkeys macaque monkeys visual
regions and you can see how they're
wired together
there's this hierarchy information comes
in the bottom of this diagram and goes
and reads the regions every one of those
little lines is a bi-directional
connection
they're not symmetric so you can tell
which is a feed forward pathway which is
the feedback pathway
so this is not a it's not a symmetrical
connection between those regions
now you might look at this and say my
gosh this is so complex how could we
ever figure this out it's going to take
hundreds of years
well it turns out that this is what the
macaque monkey looks like and humans
have a different map and cats have a
different map and dogs have a different
map and mice have a different map
and it turns also out that if you
rearrange this or chop some of these out
or plug in the auditory nerve into this
thing it still works
in fact what we've learned from the
amazing as it is is that the different
regions in new york cortex are all doing
principally the same thing and um and
what what role they play is where they
are in this hierarchy and what kind of
data they're coming in
so you know the way the brain handles
auditory information the same way it
handles uh visual information and
somatosensory information
um so we can look at this and say you
know what i don't need to understand
to understand the principles of the
brain i don't need to understand why
macaque monkey's brains wired this way i
need to understand what those regions
are doing
how regions work in a hierarchy and
pretty much if you you arrange
within a very broad set of parameters
it's going to work now
we don't see the same way as a cat in
the dog see but we all see so we
have different capabilities but the
basic same principles are occurring
there so
we don't need to understand that level
of wiring but we do need to send the
nature of hierarchies and we need to
understand
um the nature of those uh what each of
those regions is doing
um so back to our thing here so what are
those regions doing uh i
and other people have proposed that one
of the primary uh functions that's going
on
in each region of the hierarchy is
sequence memory
in fact i'll i'll claim that 90 of the
memory in your brain 90 of synapses i
believe are storing
temporal patterns or transitions
now why is that you may not think about
that because not everyone thinks about
sequence memory
but you can think about it this way
first of all just think about inference
the way you recognize things in the
world
it's all time based patterns uh so my
speech is a time based pattern if you
if you change the order of the of the
innervations on your ear
it wouldn't sound like anything at all
touch is a time-based pattern when i
pick
up something like this this coke can i
actually have to move my fingers over
things
and move my muscles before to actually
send something you just put something in
your hand you really can't you can't
you can't feel it you don't know what it
is you have to move through time and
that time-based pattern is very
important
vision is also a time-based pattern i'm
constantly moving my eyes three or four
times a second things are moving in the
world
it turns out that we can recognize still
images if they're flashed in front of
your eyes very briefly we have some
visual capabilities to do that that's
sort of like recognizing a song based on
the first chord of the song if you will
we have some limited abilities to do
that yet that's not what real vision is
like although that's
about 95 of computer vision has focused
on still images
so but that's not what vision is it's
all about time time-based inference and
of course
we also generate behavior from the
neocortex
and that is a time-based sequence so my
speech right now is being generated by
the neurons in my neocortex
and it's playing back these very complex
patterns that have been learned
and so i can i can give the speech again
and i can repeat this sentence and i can
repeat the sentence i can do it all the
time i'm playing back patterns i've
learned in the past
and so it's all about sequence memory at
least a large part of it is and the nice
big idea is that each each region in the
cortex
text it's looking for the the spatial
tempo uh components of an input stream
it collects those in time as you go up
the hierarchy of slower changing
patterns
and when you come down the hierarchy
you're unfolding time okay
my fourth principle here is that
everywhere you look in the brain
you see sparse representations it's
various typical representations this is
everywhere in the neocortex
every other piece of neural tissue on
the on the uh
the the input patterns that are coming
in and so on
so we'll find at any point in time
you'll see very few percentages of the
neurons are active
and uh most of them are inactive that's
and it's always like that
uh and it turns out that that's an
important very very important
we now begin to understand why sparse
distributed representations are
essential
for how information is represented in
the brain i'm going to talk about that
in detail
the fifth principle here is the fact
that every part of the neocortex every
region is doing both sensory or
inference and motor behavior
we used to think that the brain as the
neocortex has these input areas and
they're still calling that way
so the auditory you know the um the
optic nerve projects the v1 and it goes
up and around it gets processed and it
comes out and you speak it's like you
know the information goes in and out and
comes out the other end
we now know that's not true every region
in the inner cortex
has uh these cells in layer five which
project some place
that are motor so there is no pure audit
no pure
input and there's no pure output parts
of the air cortex every region is doing
inference and
motor behavior a really beautiful result
to understand that
and we need to make sure that we
understand uh our theories have to take
that into account and finally oops i go
to further
yeah finally my last my last point here
is that when you have a complex
hierarchy
you need to have an attentional
mechanism you can't attend to all your
inputs at once you have to be able to
tune in and tune out
um and focus on big parts of your of
your input space
and we in the brain that's done through
a thermic loop through the thalamus
there's a lot that's not understood
about that but i believe you're going to
have a complex system that's
uh of any reasonable size you're going
to have to have an intentional mechanism
in it
so these are my top six items uh one
could argue about them i'm not here to
argue this is perfect
there shouldn't be more there shouldn't
be less the point is i think you can
define a set of principles
um and this is my best guess at it but
that if we need we need to understand
how these things work
and if we do we will be able to build uh
intelligent machines
now i'm also going to argue that these
six principles are both necessary and
sufficient
so you're going to have to have all of
them and if you have them i believe
that's sufficient
for both biological and machine
intelligence every mammal has these
and my mouse has all six of these
principles you do too
but i don't think there's a single
computer in the world today that has
more than three of them and that's even
questionable
again notice here i don't say you have
to have language i don't think you have
to have human-like emotions
you don't even have to have a physical
body those are not the principles that
we care about this is a learning system
learning a a sensory motor model of the
world
okay i'm going to now talk about two of
these in depth
i'm going to talk about sparse
distributed representations and sequence
memory
so let's start with sparse distributed
representations the easiest way to
understand this is to compare to the
kind of representations you see in a
computer
in the computer we have what we call
dense representations
you might think of this as a byte or a
word anything up to 128 bits
uh we tend to we generally consider all
combinations of zeros and ones that's
why they're called dents you can have
all ones in a representation all zeros
and so on
a good example is eight bit ascii
someone tell me to be quiet or something
like that no no
8-bit ascii uh showing the letter m here
now it's interesting that
um the individual bits in a code like
ascii don't really mean anything
uh it's in you know they have no
inherent and semantic meaning
it's an arbitrary assignment we could
have picked a different combination of
bits that represent m the
the computer itself knows nothing about
what that represents
representation means it's all in the in
the programmer's mind
uh what that is and uh by convention
um and so uh that's those are the
attributes we have for those dense
representations
in a brain it's very different in the
brain we have thousands of bits if you
will you think about when i say a bit
i'm going to talk about neurons so it's
like if i say a bit there's one that's a
neuron that's active and so on so
we have we have thousands actually
hundreds of millions of these things and
all throughout the brain um but you
can't really think about even
a representation unless you have at
least several thousand of these guys
going at once
and they're mostly zeros they're mostly
quiet as i said earlier and there's only
a few ones
so for the purpose of my talk i'm going
to use an example where we have two
thousand bits which is on the small side
uh two percent of them are active so i
have 41 bits and 1960 zero bits
and that's our representation it's a lot
more bits than we're using in
for example ascii now the difference
here is that each bit has semantic
meaning
each bit has something it means
something about the real world
and epic bit becomes active when that
thing in the real world is occurring or
we're thinking about it um and so uh
and those those meanings are learned no
one assigns them no one's going to come
along and say this bit means this means
this the brain has to learn those
representations
um but then when it forms a
representation basically picks the top
two percent
attributes that match it's a competitive
process all these guys all these sort of
attributes are are competing with one
another the neurons are competing with
one another
and the ones that best match this
current state are the ones that become
active
the example i often use and it's just an
example because you wouldn't do this
but if i wanted to represent the letters
of the alphabet in a sparse distributed
representation and i wanted to hand code
it
i could say there's different bits that
represent if this is a vowel or a
consonant
what does it sound like does it a e
sound an o sound does it close or open
how do you write it does it have a
senders or descenders where is it in the
alphabet what other meanings does that
letter have
etc and then i could come up with a
representation for each
each uh each letter based on that kind
of thing now some really nice
properties that come about from using
sparse distributed representations
i'm just going to talk about a few of
them that relate mostly to intelligence
there's a bunch of other ones that
relate to the efficiencies and things
like that so here's some of the
properties that uh that we can talk
about
the simplest one is now if i want to
compare
if i compare two representations and i
just look for a bit by bit comparison
i immediately can see what they share
semantically
i don't have to have an additional data
structure i don't have a different
different operation
basically if they have the same cells
active the same bits in the same
location
they are sharing semantic properties um
and i and this doesn't happen by chance
and so this is always very significant
if i had two of these representations
and they even just had five bits in
common
that's a very significant statistically
very very significant
uh correlation and we could say those
things are highly correlated in certain
attributes and we can even talk about
what those attributes were if we knew
what they were
the second thing is you might say well
what if i wanted to
store one of these uh these vectors
these patterns
and see if it occurred again a very
common operation
so we're not going to store all 2000
bits what we're going to do is we're
going to say look all of them have 40
ones about 2
of the bits active so we're just going
to store the indexes of the
indices of the 40 active bits and so
this is being a brain like saying i
don't need to know the state of all the
cells i only need to know the state of
the few cells that are active i need to
connect to those guys because if i see
them i know i have the same pattern now
this is true if my new pattern comes in
and i look at the indices let's see oh
they have the ones in the same locations
that's a perfect match i'm good to go i
only have to store 40 of those
indices it turns out that if i couldn't
store all 40 if i said you can only
store a subset
your sub sample of them maybe 10 of
those 40
and i randomly picked the 10 you could
store and now you come in here's a new
pattern you say oh yeah the 10 bits
match
great it's a perfect match they say oh
wait it's not a perfect match because i
only think about the other 30 bits
well it's true the chances of the other
30 bits being totally different is
very very low but even if it is
different it doesn't matter because i've
made a mistake for something that's
semantically very similar to the thing i
stored earlier
so i stored something different earlier
but now i get something that's
semantically similar and that's good
enough and we actually it's a desirable
property
next thing we're going to do is just one
more property we're going to talk about
which is union membership
and this is going to be important
because i'm going to talk about brains
making predictions and brains have to
make multiple predictions at the same
time you have to be able to predict
multiple possible next events in the
world and you have to deal with the same
set of cells you can't do it with a
different set of cells or different
buffers someplace
so one thing we can do is we can form a
union of of these sparse distributed
representations so i have 10 different
sparks to stupid representations i just
ordered them together
i have a new one now which has instead
of having 40 bits active it has 400 bits
active
about 20 um and i said okay well i can't
undo that it's a one-way street
so i can't say oh what were the 10 items
that were in that unit can't do that
but i can do something almost as good
which is i can say here's a new pattern
a new sparse distributed representation
and say is it one of the members of the
original 10 by comparing it to the union
and i can do that all i have to do is
say well let's see if the bits in my new
unknown match up the bits in the union
i'm going to say it's one of the
original 10.
and you can say wow i could make a
mistake yeah i could be picking someone
from one of those 10 and some ones from
the other one and someone's the other
one
again extremely unlikely to happen just
statistically
but even if you did do it you would be
making something for semantically a
mistake for something that's
semantically similar to the things you
stored before
and that's often good enough for us so
we're going to use that in our
in our predictions inside of a brain
because when you predict things you're
constantly predicting
multiple events and you need to know if
they actually occurred or something
different occurred
okay now i've said this many times i'll
say here again today
if you want anyone remember one thing
about my talk today is remember that the
future of intelligent machines is sparse
distributed representations
this is the language of the brain it's
going to be the language of machines
intelligence it solves a very very hard
problem
of representation in ai which is you
know
this is this is befuddled ai researchers
forever it's like how what are the data
structures
what are the schemas by which i
represent knowledge about the world
and this is the way the brain does it
and i i
suggest it's going to be the way we're
going to do it in in our artificial
brains as well
okay uh now i'm going to switch to
sequence memory
uh again i told you this is a very very
key part in my company we spent several
years trying to figure out how to do
this
uh it was very very hard maybe we were
just slow
but here are some of the constraints
that we had to solve these are
theoretical constraints uh we first of
all we have to
we want to discover the temporal
structure in large arrays of sensory
data
imagine i've got a region of cells a
region in the neocortex and i'm feeding
in millions of bits
or hundreds of thousands of bits of
information to it in parallel
and i'm trying to discover the this
temple structure in this very very large
typically two dimensional array of bits
um how do you begin with that it's not
like a simple input
there's topology in the brain so you
know there's uh the parts you know the
left side of the retina projects
a certain part of the v1 and so on and
that's part of the answer there too we
have to respect that
the system has to learn online we've
already talked about that
the input patterns will be very noisy in
fact it's in a real brain
it's very likely that you'll never see
the same pattern twice
ever on any of your sensory input
streams uh you'll never have the same
pattern twice coming on your optic nerve
in your entire life and yet you have to
learn the statistics of the world
from that very noisy and constantly
changing uh input stream
uh we have to be able to learn very high
order sequences this is uh because we
as humans can learn high order sequences
speech is a very high order sequence
music is the very hardest sequence
your ability to navigate through a world
through this building is very high order
you know where you are and as you're
following down hallways and so on
we have to be able to make multiple
simultaneous predictions we have to be
able to detect anomalies and we have to
generalize as the memory fills
so these are all very difficult things
to solve in some sort of
a data structure um so how does the
brain we think we know how the brain
does this so this
we're pretty confident that we got this
good part of it so we're going to try to
solve all those constraints
um a little bit more neuroscience here
we can start off we
look at the this uh this is a picture of
the brain up at the top here
if i look at a piece of the neocortex
these are this is a slice in the air
cortex is about two millimeters thick
and there are typically five layers it
depends on how you count but let's say
five
layers of cells anywhere you look in the
near quarter it doesn't matter what
region
there's these these layers of cells
there and i argue that if the neocortex
is doing pretty much the same thing
everywhere
and a big part of what it's doing is
sequence memory and temporal prediction
that that's going on in this structure
and i'm going to move further to say
that i believe that all the layers of
cells all five layers of cells here are
all doing a type of sequence memory
some are doing motor output some are
doing feed forward inference some are
doing attention
um and so there's a there's common
architecture across these these
different
layers of cells and i'm trying to get at
those principles by which that common
architecture works
so it doesn't really matter which one
we're going to look at here the
principles i'm going to talk about are
generally applicable to all of them
not 100 but pretty close if you look at
one of those slices
here's a little diagram i made these
little circles are supposed to represent
the neurons
there's about 10 000 neurons in a cubic
millimeter of
10 000 excitatory cells a cubic
millimeter of new york cortex so they're
really packed in there
you see two connectivity schemes here
the green one is
that the cells in the columnar structure
there's not a lot of connections going
that way but they tend to all respond to
the same
feed forward response property they tend
to be have the same sort of
response to the world especially in a
simple um
feed forward pattern but most of the
connections ninety percent of them
are are to to cells nearby or further
away
it's not that columnar thing they're
spread out within the within the region
also to other regions uh if you look at
any one of those cells
this is that picture again from alcohol
back many many years ago
and we zoom in on one of these you see
the connections are all along the
dendritic tree they're not on the cell
body
along the dendritic tree and the
dendrite here's a blown a picture of a
section of a dendrite right here
uh in this case you can see these little
spines either the actual synapses are
about a micron apart
and what we now know is that there's
these very strong non-linearities in the
dendrites
so what does that mean it means if i
have a section of dendrite let's say 40
microns wide
and i have maybe 15 or 20 synapses
become active
within a small time window a few
milliseconds
that if that happens then there will be
a dendritic spike
a very non-linear event that actually
can depolarize the cell body
significantly and i'm going to argue
that's a predictive state
but if um if those same number of
synapses i had the same 15 cinemas but
they were to spread over the
over different parts of the dendrite you
don't have that effect there's almost no
effect of the cell body
very minimal so these guys out here kind
of act like coincidence detectors all
these little branches are like
coincidence
detectors out there looking for a
coincident activity of patterns
of inputs at the very same time we're
going to model this
in our models this is a picture of the
neurons we use in our models
these little color dots are the synapses
we
actually make a distinction between what
are called the proximal synapses which
be
these are ones that are very close to
the cell body um right close to the cell
body up here they actually
they behave differently than the ones
that are further away and so we have to
i'm not getting into that difference
today
but these are the ones that actually get
connected to feed forward input so if i
follow the
you know if i'm following the optic
nerve coming into v1 and it goes through
the thalamus and it goes here they
connect to those
these distal ones are the ones that
connect in the orange pathway
farther away so that's that's shown here
so sort of this
this sort of columnar feed forward
activation is turned to the proximal
synapses
and the and the distal ones or the
further ones from the body are basically
receiving these patterns from other
places along
other other cells nearby and those are
acting like coincidence detectors
next thing we're going to do is we're
going to put this in a structure that's
a layer of cells with columns
and we're and this is of course just a
small picture of one and we're going to
say okay
what is that sheet of cells how does
this learn sequences
how does it how does it make predictions
and how does it do temporal inference
uh of all the properties i mentioned
earlier
i'm going to show you a little bit about
that it takes a long time to really get
used to it
but i'll give you a flavor for it we're
going to just assume that this here's a
here's a picture of a layer of cells
it's very small it's only a very small
part of our sparse distributed
representation
and i'm showing the red ones are the
ones that are active these are the ones
we're getting that won a competition
in a feed forward competition from from
the input space so this is
representing our feed forward input if
you will and most of those cells are
inactive
at this point in time uh
now we're going to say well what happens
in a moment later we have a different
set of cells
that become active so again you can just
imagine here's one more time there's
another moment time and
and this is happening all the time if
you if you could look inside of your
brain right now
and the reasons that are hearing or
seeing you're gonna you see this kind of
crazy act
on uh these sparse distribute
representations are just flying by
and we want to learn the temple
transitions here well the way that
we believe the brain does that is it
does it a cell at a time
when a cell becomes active any cell
becomes active it wins sort of the feed
forward competition
it looks for other cells that were
active recently in the past
um that are nearby and it says okay i
can connect to some
some subset of them and it forms
connections to them it says if i see
those guys again
i'm going to predict my own activity i'm
going to depolarize and i'm going to be
in a predictive state saying i'm
expected to win next if every cell does
this and every cell participates in this
process
you end up with a situation like this i
might have an input
and then i have multiple predictions so
if i train the system on
an a followed by a b and a followed by c
and a followed by d and i showed a it's
going to predict b
c and d and that's what's happening in
this little diagram here
we have the red cells are being or the
active cells these other cells are all
predicting that they're going to become
active next
and we can detect whether this actually
occurs or something else occurs in the
next moment in time
now this memory as i've just shown it
here is um
is a a very interesting memory but it's
a first order memory
it only can it can only use the context
in the previous time step
has no ability to learn a song for
example because i need to know more than
just what happened to the previous note
it'd be no ability to learn a speech and
so on things like that it's just a first
order memory
and we need a high order memory and the
brain needs higher memory for motive
for inference for everything so how does
the brain do that well we have
we have a speculation on that it works
very well so i have some confidence in
it
um so first of all we're going to go
back and look at our sparse distributed
representation
here's my my zeros and ones again of say
my 2000 bits
and instead of representing each one of
these by a single cell this is my
feedforward input i'm going to represent
each one by a column of cells
so the feed forward pattern i instead
activates an entire column
of cells and i'm just showing 10 cells
in the column right here so this
this is uh these are all the cells up
here and we've just taken every cell in
the previous picture and expanded into a
column
now i'm going to randomly uh that we
don't do this in actuality but i'm going
to
assume for a moment we randomly choose
one cell in each of the active columns
so if the column is active
that is the feedforward pattern matched
then i'm going to pick randomly one of
those cells and another one another one
another one
at a different point in time i might
have the exact same input coming in
the exact same pattern coming on the on
the the input fibers or
from your sensors but i want to
represent it differently in a different
context
so the exact same pattern coming in from
an in from a feed forward point of view
activates the exact same column so i
have the exact same columns active here
but i'm going to randomly pick cells in
here again and so most of these cells
will be different than the previous one
in this case 90 of them 9 out of 10
would be different on average
and those two patterns are very
differentiatable so i have the ability
to say at one
one level of analysis i have the same
pattern coming in in a different level
analysis i have a very different pattern
and this is how you can cannot get lost
in a song when there's repeating
repeating notes and how you know you
know in the same thing when
in my speech if i use different words in
different contexts and so on how you
differentiate them okay this is the
basic principle
that and there's got to be something
like this but we believe this is what
the columnist structure is doing in the
neocortex
so uh just to give you a sense for the
capacity of this if i just have a very
small memory of 40 active columns and
there's 10 cells per column then there's
10 to the 40th ways to represent the
same input in different contexts
most of those will be equally far apart
in having distance
so this is a very very large capacity to
represent many many different
the same element in many many different
contexts okay uh
i'm not gonna show exactly how all this
works but basically the same principle
each cell
uh in these columns becomes active they
i'm just showing ones on the top here
but they connect to other cells nearby
in different columns in different
different layers and
if you do this all right and i'm not
going to walk you through it all
you end up with a variable order
sequence memory that is if the
statistics
can allow it it'll learn very long
sequences
in multiple simultaneous predictions it
can be very high capacity empirically
we've tested this
and we can tell you without a doubt even
a very small system like this can learn
millions of transitions without getting
confused
uh it's it gets tricky to to put actual
numbers on explain what those are cause
it depends on the statistics of the data
it's distributed in fault tolerance so
there's nothing in this system that's
that's critical i can drop out synapses
i can drop out dendrites and cells and
columns
up to some level and it continues to
work just fine
okay and finally it does semantic
generalization uh because
uh imagine i've learned some sequences
of patterns
uh and in the past and now i have a new
input that's coming in but somewhat
different
but it overlaps semantically with the
ones i've seen before and if it overlaps
semantically it's overlapping with bits
and therefore i can apply it prior
learning to the new patterns
and make predictions based on prior to
the new situation
that is semantically similar which is a
very nice property and one we need
okay so uh i'm going to leave it at that
there's so there's a lot of details on
this if you want to get into the into
the details about it there's a white
paper describes all the how all this
works
uh and there's been multiple independent
implementations of this algorithm
i'm now going to switch gears briefly
i'm going to talk about applying this in
a real world problem
again as i said earlier i think it's
important to do that um
and it's it's the way i work i'm a
business person as much as a scientist
or
engineer and uh to me it's this is a
great way of testing your theories
making sure they're working
and validating their their practical
applications so we're applying this
in the world of data and uh this is
describing the world of data today
mostly today
you have with lots of sources of data in
the world we stick them in databases
and then what do we do with them well
typically what we'll do is we'll have an
analyst who looks at some visualization
of the data and spends time trying to
figure out what's going on in it
they might create models of the data
these are usually hand-crafted models
a lot of a lot of arcane science that
goes into doing these
and if you do that right you can make
predictions about the data the
challenges they face today is that
there's a lot of data preparation
problems
the models get obsolete because the
world is changing and so
and it takes lots of people so anyone
who works in data science will tell you
this is a problem where the world is
going
we're interested in part of the world
the future of data and which is
sometimes called machine to machine
sometimes called the internet of things
sometimes called the industrial internet
but basically everything in the world is
becoming a sensor
everything door knobs windows buildings
cars
streets lights they all can generate
data
and uh we're just scratching the surface
of this and already there's way too much
of this stuff
uh and and we we need to figure out how
to take advantage of this data
in useful ways and so if you think about
this uh there's there's really there's
no possibility
if if i have billions of things in the
world and i really mean billions of
things in the world that are streaming
data
from sensors on motors and cars and
windmills and so on
uh we can't have analysts look at this
stuff uh we don't even
don't even want to store it in fact most
of the data be being sensed today is not
actually stored
and the vast majority of the data that's
stored is never looked at
it's been well documented so what we
need to go to a world where
the sensors in the world create data
streams they go right into online models
there's no storage of the data you don't
even keep it unless you need it for
forensic purposes you act on it
immediately
and you keep going and these models have
to be
automated you have to be able to create
them automatically they have to be
continuous learning that says online
learning
and they need to look for the tempo and
spatial structure in the in the data
well that hopefully will you'll
recognize it that's exactly what brains
do
right brains take streaming data they
build models from it they make
predictions
and they detect anomalies and a
continuous learning
so we said let's see if we can apply
these algorithms that we created
to this kind of problem and that's what
we've been doing
uh we've created this product called
grok which is the engine for acting on
streaming data
the basic idea behind it is we take
structured data or semi-structured data
in in the field in records with fields
and multiple one or more fields here
we run them through a set of encoders
that can be fairly generic you don't
have to hand tune those encoders
those are like your sensory organs so it
turns like a
like a float or a scale or value into a
sparse distributed representation in a
way i'm not going to get into right now
but we modeled it after the cochlea so
we end up with a bunch of sparse student
representations
we feed them through our our uh our
cortical sequence memory here
and out become predictions anomalies and
then we turn those and we wrap this in a
whole product so the customer can take
actions on it
and um the user basically has to access
the data they have to define their
problem
the grok basically builds the models it
does an evolutionary search for over
certain parameters like what are the
best what are the best fields what are
the best ways of encoding them
so these structures here can go under an
evolutionary
approach just like our our sensory
organs have
but this part does not this is just a
learning section here
um and then uh the outcome of all this
is they can do useful things
we've been finding lots of customer
interest in this uh lots of people
waking up that this is a real big
important part of future of data so
we're doing a lot of work in energy
and energy pricing energy demand
real-time sort of reaction like oh the
price of electricity is going to be up
later this afternoon i should pre-cool a
building now type of thing
product forecasting ad network return
machine efficiencies
lots and lots of different applications
i'm just going to give you a flavor for
what it looks like i don't want to try
to sell you on this product i'm just
trying to give you a sense
here's a very very simple application
this is the simplest one i could
i can show you this is the energy
electrical energy consumption of
a factory in france um that and this is
the five days of the week this is the
weekend
this is what it looks like it's it's
sampled every five minutes
and the customer wanted the new the
following thing they said at midnight
i want to be able to predict what the
hourly energy consumption will be for
the next 24 hours
and uh and so we can do that in rock
with a bunch of other
stuff around it that i haven't told you
about but essentially this is a picture
of brock's actuals and predicted
values you really can't tell if it's
doing a good job by looking at this
picture but it is doing a good job the
customer's very happy with it
so and we have various ways of measuring
that i'm not going to get into at this
point in time
the point i want to show you is it's
just that grock doesn't have there's no
expectation about what this is supposed
to look like
he has no idea what the typical patterns
are going to be it could be it has no
assumptions prior assumptions about what
this data is representing it doesn't
know
he says just show me the data and i'm
going to try to i'm going to try to
build a predictive model
and i will do it as high order as i can
here's another example which is really
the same problem but it's a very
harder one to visualize this is
predicting
the demand for a server service
basically video encoding
and so a customer has to accept videos
from uh on on
through on the web they have to encode
them and stream them back out to the uh
to their clients and the demand is very
peaky so this
these two lines here the blue line is
the is the the actual demand
on this service and it's very peaky it's
very hard to predict um and so because
of that they have to leave lots of extra
servers
online all the time anticipating that
there might be a peak in demand
and so if you could just do a slightly
better than any other algorithm
predicting what the demand would be
you then you could save a lot of money
because you could reduce the number of
servers you're keeping online
so this is the the red stuff is grox
predictions again you really can't tell
how we're doing
but the customer is very happy in this
regard we did much better than do with
their old machine learning experts
now why is that it looks almost like
it's unpredictable well it turns out
that
there are patterns here they change very
rapidly news cycles come and go
maybe certain times of the day and and
these patterns are changing literally on
a daily basis
this is not like if you look at what
happened three three weeks ago it's
meaningless
it's like what happened this morning
what happened yesterday what are the
patterns that are occurring
uh what are the typical cycles and grack
is constantly learning trying to predict
and it can just do better than other
techniques that are more static
okay one final example here just to
delve into some of the internals to give
you a flavor what it looks like
this is you can this is like if you're
looking down on this little slice of
neocortex that we model
and these are these are actually 2048
columns
these are all these little circles the
green ones are ones that are currently
active
for the current input and they were also
predicted so this is a point in the data
point where it says i predicted one
thing to occur
and i got it nailed it on simple
problems you see this a lot
on more complex problems you don't see
it here's another scenario where
the little blue circles are things that
were predicted that didn't occur that's
not an error
that's just as i predicted multiple
things but the thing that did occur the
green dots was one of the things that
was predicted so i predicted one of
multiple things it's a perfect match in
some sense
we're happy about that um here's a
situation where
things were kind of mixed we have some
columns that were predicted and became
active we had some columns that were not
pretty
were predicted did not become active and
these little red guys are ones that
weren't predicted
and they became active so those are
anomalies and so you can see from this
an anomaly is not a
a binary thing it's actually a graded
thing we can even if we
if we had the ability to we could look
at and see what are the semantic
properties of this prediction that were
wrong
or the input that were wrong what parts
were submitted what parts of the input
were right
and what parts were wrong and you have
the brain has the ability to go do this
and this is just a picture of a tool we
use internally
we use it uh we also use this an anomaly
prediction this is
my favorite drawing for this this is the
uh the temperature of a gearbox oil in
an offshore windmill in the north
north sea and so this is every every
minute or so this temperature of the
gearbox is measured
and it's going up and down very rapidly
during the day as the gearbox goes
speeds up and slows down
and what we're trying to do is
detectives are some kind of anomaly in
this data stream
and this red line is how good is grok
predicting
what the temperature is going to be uh
next and
and in the very beginning it's never
seen this before so it's got a high peak
here it says i can't predict very well
it starts learning
they changed out something on the
windmill here so it's had to start
learning again
here's a relatively long period of of uh
you know normal operation we don't know
that just says okay so settle down
and then here it peaks up again and that
turned out to be a failure in the
gearbox
and it wasn't out of range it wasn't out
of uh it wasn't too high or too low but
the temple dynamics were different at
this point than
what it's seen recently and gracken said
hey that's different something might be
happening there
so um let me just go on here so that's
that's
uh this stuff really works uh i'm not
saying it's perfect but it really works
it's we've tested this extensively over
the years
and it's a very cool system i think so
um
we are taking this and turning into an
open source project uh
i this might be one of the first places
i've actually talked about this uh we've
had a lot of interest from both
academics and uh
industrial people you know people in the
industry in these algorithms
there have been multiple implementations
of the algorithms because we put out a
white paper
three and a half years ago and described
them to some level
and that wipers now white paper was uh
translated in
the seven languages by volunteers it's
about a 70 page white paper so it's not
a trivial task to do that
so we said hey there's a lot of interest
in this so let's uh let's satisfy the
interest
so we're turning all this algorithmic
source code we're putting it into an
open source product we're calling new
pic
for the memphis platform for intelligent
computing it's going to be on your gpl
version 3 license if that means anything
to you
uh we're launching this oops we're
launching this officially in july i'm
giving a speech at the open source
conference
and in case there were one or two people
in this room were interested we're
having a
pre-launch hackathon june 21st in red
ridge city if you're interested to speak
to me later
um and our goal is just you know my goal
is to be a catalyst i'm just trying to i
love this stuff i love brains i love
mental machine intelligence i want to
see it happen
in my lifetime and i'm doing my best
right or wrong
um and my goal is to be a catalyst for
machine intelligence that's trying to be
a multiplier you know don't get consumed
but accelerate the reaction
um so now on to the last part of my talk
how am i doing on time-wise perfect okay
oh no i'm zero
oh zero that's not good oh bad
bad bad well i'm not going to speed up
sorry um
but it won't be that long what's the
future machine intelligence is it bad
like these things you know do you
recognize those guys
or is it good like these things we can
have robot butlers and playing games
with computers and putting funny things
on our head and
stimulating our brains or is it
something nebulous in between like how
who knows i'm going to say but there's
some things i can say here's some things
i can say definitely
we can build bigger and faster brains
than artificial brains and real brains
there's no reason we can't build
artificial brains that have bigger
capacity and run a million times faster
than a human brain
we can create all kinds of super senses
we are limited in our senses we have to
get everything in the world
genetic genetics and and particle
physics we have to filter them through
our eyes and ears we could potentially
create senses that are more directly
related to the things we're trying to
learn about
and that's very very cool uh we can do
fluid robotics this is like this is
going to blow open in the next 20 years
but we haven't even touched this yet and
of course we can do distributed
hierarchies my brain has to be all
located in my head
but artificial brains don't have to be
that way we could distribute parts of
the hierarchy in different places and
they could communicate with each other
and so there's all kinds of interesting
opportunities there
things that might happen we might have
humanoid robots i don't know we might
have computer brain interfaces for all i
don't know
these might not happen i'm not certain
about them things that are not going to
happen
we're not going to upload your brain so
computers sorry if you're looking
forward to that it's not going to happen
i can explain why later but i'm just i'm
pretty confident saying that there's a
lot of people really interested in this
but they don't understand biology
um they're we're not gonna have evil
robots taking over the world the only
thing you have to worry about is
self-replication
this is not about self-replication we're
not building machines that want to
replicate and fornicate and do all that
kind of stuff
um that's that's someone else's problem
don't let people do self-replication
and it's not of course not going to be
friendlies only so those are some of my
prognostications
uh last slide why should we do this why
should you care
i can think of two big reasons uh one is
we can make life better
uh you know the computers have improved
our life so much
and enriched humanity so much in the
last 60 years
and i think we can continue that i think
machine intelligence is going to even do
better than that over the next coming 50
years
uh i think we can just you know make the
world more efficient safer
uh healthier in many many ways in the
same way that computers have done that
but i also believe that you know the
ultimate goal in life
if you ask yourself what's the purpose
of life it's kind of dismal if you have
a very pragmatic
look at it but i think it's to learn the
only thing i can think about is we need
to learn about our universe and we need
to make sure that knowledge is
transferred to future generations for
whatever purpose
and i can think of no better way of
accelerating accretion of knowledge than
building really fast intelligent
machines
physicists that never get tired and
mathematicians that run a million times
faster and don't
you know and love it and i think that's
going to happen
in our lifetime so that's it thanks
ahead of time yeah so the question was i
showed these uh
these predictions overlapping nicely
with the data but how much ahead of time
were they actually made
well the algorithm i showed you really
only predicts one step at a time it's a
very short-term prediction
you could run that algorithm forward
multiple steps you could take your
predictions of feeder man and during the
next thing
um but the algorithm itself only
predicts one like one
you know short period of time in the
future but we we actually had customer
requests to do more than that as i said
someone wants to predict 24 hours in
advance how did we do that well we
cheated we didn't do it the way brains
do it's not a cheat we solved the
customer problem
so what we do is uh we took we added an
external classifier
that essentially says all right take the
state of the system the internal state
of the system those cells that are
active
which represents all knowledge of the
world in the context of the of the
current data stream
and i classify that a very simple
classifier um
to some future value that might occur 24
hours in advance we can do this
automatically so it doesn't require any
human intervention
but some of those applications we did
that we did that sort of non-biological
extra step if i just want to predict the
next step then i didn't need to do that
somehow next step seems very cheap
because i just predict
the same value right well oh very good
question the next step seems cheap you
said because i could just predict the
same value
so we're constantly doing we call that
the trivial predictor uh the trivial
predictors just assume the last
data points the next data point we
always test against that
and we're always testing to make sure we
do much better than it if we can't do
much better than
we just we tell the customer we're not
doing better than trivial
but that is built into the software to
constantly check for that
you know if you have a very sick very
slowly varying variable
and you're saying over sampling it well
yeah you can do that very well
but what we typically find is that in
the in the real world problems that
customers want to solve there's a lot of
variation in the data between the time
they make
the the last data point in the next
prediction so you know that someone
might want to predict the energy
consumption in an hour from now
every hour well it's it's not it's not
necessarily smooth we can also predict
you know categories uh
that have no continuous no continuity to
the curves whatsoever
the system is not limited to that kind
of prediction but you have to be careful
you'll be very very careful not to fool
yourself
into into thinking you're doing a good
job when you're actually doing something
trivial
so we have to test that all the time
have we looked at the evolved model and
there's meaning we can extract from like
what is
what do these actually bits represent is
that what you mean by that
yeah so it does although our world that
we're applying it to today are fairly
small and simple
so we did we did a lot of work in vision
computer vision to test this model
and sure enough we find the kind of
typical features you see in v1
like the lines and edges and corners and
things like that um
in these models here we can also say
what it mean you know we can we can
ascribe some value to it but they're
kind of trivial these are these are very
small systems
you know that model there is a
thousandth the size of a mouse in your
cortex and a millionth of size or human
neocortex
and so you're not going to get any
really deep deep knowledge out of it
um but we have done that you can look at
a bit and say what you there's tricks we
can do to say what does this bit
represent
uh but you know we didn't get any we
didn't get any great insights about the
world of you know philosophy from that
um
it's pretty pretty simple all right
yeah yeah
yeah it's a great question the question
essentially is
hey i said the brain is an online
learning mechanism but in reality in
real brains
as you heard yesterday the hippocampus
is actually where you temporarily store
things
and then sleep seems to be necessary to
transfer that later to the um
uh to the cortex at some future date i
think that's what your question is about
um i true very good observation
there's a level of detail i didn't want
to get into here i still
hold that both the hippocamp is an
online learning system
and even when it transfers it to the
near cortex it's an online learning
system
um and there's no ability because it
could hit the the hippocampus itself
is not a total data dump it's not that
you know no one can you can't go look at
local let's look at the
let's look at the statistics of the
day's data it can play back things in
the same way
so i'll stick to my my um my claim
although you're absolutely right that in
a real brain there's a lot more stuff
going on and that's true for a lot of
the stuff i talked about
the question is are we getting close to
the principles that apply
and um and you have to you just have to
somehow deal with these
incongruities sometimes and try to
understand them so it's a very good
question
okay thank you very much